Leandro Suarez: Bueno en sí. Lo que es medio. La selección de clases es lo que veníamos hablando. Lo ideal sería que haya una selección aleatoria, o sea, lo ideal, porque después todas las claves serían
Leandro Suarez: equis probables.
Leandro Suarez: Pero, bueno, por lo general son difíciles de memorizar, como decíamos, y el usuario prefiere elegir una contraseña. En
Leandro Suarez: hay algunos tipos de claves que se utilizaron en su momento, que son las claves pronunciables
Leandro Suarez: suelen ser palabras así sin sin sentido, pero que son fáciles de recordar, digamos, y
Leandro Suarez: nada. He visto. Ot, otra especie de.
Leandro Suarez: de, digamos, de de de métodos para para poder simplificar un poco y no ser tan evidente.
Leandro Suarez: Y, Pero, bueno, estamos siempre tenemos alguna especie de riesgo
Leandro Suarez: muy fácil de adivinar. Es difícil de memorizar. Los possword Manager, tema de la clave maestra, tener mucho cuidado. Si te la roban, te roban todas las passwords.
Leandro Suarez: Entonces, bueno, es es realmente un tema escabroso. El tema de la selección de graves y
Leandro Suarez: la fuerza bruta, no a la hora de un atacante que debe vulnerar.
Leandro Suarez: Me vuelvo para atrás para algo de Había quedado claro
Leandro Suarez: preven en lo que es prevenciones, digamos
Leandro Suarez: como prevenimos los ataques, ya sea offline como o online dentro de nuestro sistema para
Leandro Suarez: evitar algún tipo de ataque offline en general. Uno puede asumir
Leandro Suarez: que a F y C no sean conocidas simultáneamente, sino medio que se terminó el problema.
Leandro Suarez: pero efe suele ser conocido o puede conocerse de alguna forma. No a ver. Uno puede probar esos algoritmos hasta
Leandro Suarez: hasta tratar de pegarle con el algoritmo que usa el sistema hoy. Hay muchos algoritmos bastante estándar de industria.
Leandro Suarez: por no decir que son poquitos, incluso. Entonces, bueno, quizás que esa parte sea un poco más sencilla, o incluso se puede hacer una especie de reversi cheniling para determinar qué se está utilizando como F,
Leandro Suarez: entonces eso no dará la pauta que tendríamos que
Leandro Suarez: protegerse, no más que nada porque ya no lo controlamos nosotros. Lo controla el usuario
Leandro Suarez: de esto como ejemplo se puede dar en lo que es el archivo hallado de Urix, que era lo que se protegía forma que solamente Ruth puede acceder a ese a ese archivo, ¿no?
Leandro Suarez: Ahora, para el caso de los ataques online
Leandro Suarez: es un poquito más más interesante o o o es un poco más más dinámico, No, porque lo que tenemos que proteger justamente es el uso de la función de autenticación.
Leandro Suarez: Hay distintos distintos mecanismos para protegerlo de distintas protecciones.
Leandro Suarez: Uno de ellos suele ser el
Leandro Suarez: lo que se conoce como ponencia al back off.
Leandro Suarez: que es básicamente un algoritmo donde cuando hay una falla, se aumenta el tiempo de reintento exponencialmente. O sea.
Leandro Suarez: voy fallo? Bueno, Pero en un segundo, bueno, fallo pregón entre bueno, fallo, pero en 10 y así, y cada vez es, se empieza a aumentar el tiempo de espera para que para evitar alguna fuerza bruta, para evitar que incluso tiren abajo el sistema.
Leandro Suarez: hay distintos motivos por el que se utiliza un exponer Off. Pero en este caso es una una forma de proteger.
Leandro Suarez: Otra que se suele utilizar es desactivar o inhabilitar los el principal que está haciendo, o los principales que están siendo.
Leandro Suarez: digamos, producciones, diría, for producción o, como se llama Bruce. Ahí está que serían que están siendo forciados, o sea, los deshabilitados.
Leandro Suarez: Y de esa forma bueno.
Leandro Suarez: es medio, es medio borde porque bueno a en algún banco. Todavía queda esa política de ché. Bueno, veo que tuviste 5 intentos fallidos. Te saliste, usuario.
Leandro Suarez: es medio complejo ese tema. Algunos algunos bancos todavía lo siguen haciendo o hasta donde supe, lo seguían haciendo.
Leandro Suarez: Y es complicado porque alguien malicioso podría estar afectando la disponibilidad de un usuario por el simple hecho de joder nada más.
Leandro Suarez: Y se han des se han desarrollado unos sistemas un poco más
Leandro Suarez: versátiles para evitar este tipo de ataques también.
Leandro Suarez: Y
Leandro Suarez: otra otro tipo de de mecanismos para prevenir es el shalling o el o también puede ser el Hollypot.
Leandro Suarez: Lo usa más que nada agencias gubernamentales. Empresas muy, muy importantes que pueden
Leandro Suarez: soportar este tipo de mecanismo, que No, no es sencillo. Son básicamente cuando se detecta que hay un ataque sobre la función autenticación, lo que se hace es Switchear.
Leandro Suarez: esa función para ese atacante, por otra, que no es real.
Leandro Suarez: donde quizás no sé, le tira errores o incluso lo deja pasar, pero le deja pasar a a un ambiente controlado donde no puede hacer nada el usuario. O sea, se creyó que entró y que está hackeado, y entré. Y puedo hacer mientras tanto.
Leandro Suarez: el equipo de seguridad de esa agencia o compañía, lo que sea, lo está traciando para ver de dónde viene?
Leandro Suarez: Básicamente, Hollywood es el el inglés, que es el bote de miel para para el oso. Lo tenés al atacante ahí con el con la miel, mientras vos vas de atrás a capturarlo.
Leandro Suarez: Es algo bastante complejo de ejecutar también, pero pero se suele usar, como le digo en en empresas muy, muy importantes, en en agencias gubernamentales, en
Leandro Suarez: en más corporativo, fuerte, importante y bueno.
Leandro Suarez: después los captchas que ya lo conocemos vienen siendo recontra vulnerados últimamente. Con todo esto de hace rato, ya desde que salieron los bots
Leandro Suarez: le dieron sin parar. Y eso hace que también evolucione el captcha. Pero ya últimamente con el tema de la I A, se está poniendo muy complicado
Leandro Suarez: Y
Leandro Suarez: Y la realidad es que no sé qué va a pasar. Pero, bueno, o siguen evolucionando los captcha, pero también sigue Eu evolucionando los atacantes no es una especie de también de de forma de proteger, no una una forma bastante barata, incluso de
Leandro Suarez: protegerlo, porque hoy por hoy, el el captcha te lo da muchas empresas como como servicio, digamos
Leandro Suarez: también. Sí, sí hay. Incluso había algunos que son. Me encontré con algunos bastante complejo. Hay algunos que te dicen: bueno, mover esta pieza y encastrarla en tal lugar, ¿Qué sé yo, que capaz, que es una ya no sea tan tamaña hasta que lo estudia y lo llegan a a entrenar para que lo haga.
Leandro Suarez: Sí, sí podrían podría ser algún tipo de pregunta medio engañosa que
Leandro Suarez: o o con información que no sé de ahí ya me excede, pero
Leandro Suarez: pero sí hay captchas, encontré captchas muy.
Leandro Suarez: muy creativos por ahí. Bueno, la gente igual. El atacante generalmente suele ser más creativo que la gente que defiende.
Leandro Suarez: bueno, y otra forma no de de proteger es subir la complejidad de las claves, o sea.
Leandro Suarez: básicamente empezar a pedirle cada vez más cosas, símbolos mayúsculas, que era lo que veníamos hablando. Y hay una formulita que se llama la fórmula de Anderson, que nos permite determinar la probabilidad
Leandro Suarez: de que un atacante adivine una clave. No es básicamente sencilla. Es la probabilidad. Es igual a el tiempo dedicado a las pruebas
Leandro Suarez: por la el número de pruebas realizables por segundo dividido, el tamaño del espacio de clave.
Leandro Suarez: De esta forma se puede estimar el tiempo de un ataque en base a un a un sistema, digamos.
Leandro Suarez: y acá hay un ejercicio si alguno tiene ganas de hacerlo para no Spoilearlos.
Leandro Suarez: Básicamente, si tenemos claves numéricas de 10 dígitos, o sea, números, 10, y se puede probar 10 000 claves por Segundo, ¿cuál es el tiempo
Leandro Suarez: de búsqueda estimado para para poder tener una probabilidad de mayor a 0, 5, un atacante de adivinar una clave. No.
Leandro Suarez: no sé si a 1 lo lo quiere hacer. Le dejo la la formulita. Ahí
Leandro Suarez: Mhm.
Leandro Suarez: hay hay un un cuento, va un cuento. Es un texto de Asimov, que es la la cómo se llama la última pregunta o algo así es justamente
Leandro Suarez: tiene que ver con eso que que decidís Vos Joaquín.
Leandro Suarez: Bueno, si alguno lo lo resolvió
Leandro Suarez: exactamente.
Leandro Suarez: Sí, Bueno, ahí pusiste la fórmula está perfecto, y sacó desvelo esto?
Leandro Suarez: Bueno, usamos no mayor. Igual. La probabilidad que sea mayor igual a 0. Cinco que esperábamos
Leandro Suarez: donde acá despejamos, Ts: se invierte, digamos, el el la desigualdad, la probabilidad que buscamos de 0. Cinco.
Leandro Suarez: digamos, la el espacio de claves de 10 a las 10 y son 10 000. K, por segundo que puedo intentar termina siendo que en menos de 500 000 s o 6 días puede obtener la
Leandro Suarez: la poder llegar a tener una probabilidad mayor de 0, coma 5 de adivinar una clave.
Leandro Suarez: Esto hace que empiece a subir un poco la complejidad, no 1 empieza a pedir más cosas. Por ejemplo, el astral se han hecho letras. Entonces ya no son 10 posibles dígitos, sino 26 posibles caracteres.
Leandro Suarez: Por ejemplo, ponerle que la la capacidad de probar por segundos a la misma. Bueno, acá cambia la cosa, no
Leandro Suarez: hacemos la misma cuenta. Si obtenemos 121 días y
Leandro Suarez: subió, bastan, subió con poquitas cosas. Sube bastante la complejidad. Por una, le estás pidiendo. Incluso estás pidiendo menos
Leandro Suarez: menos largo, de clave, más fácil de acordarse, quizás.
Leandro Suarez: y cambia un montón la cosa.
Leandro Suarez: Y después 1 podría llegar a a inferir cuál cuál es el largo que y la complejidad que 1 espera para tener cierto
Leandro Suarez: para tener, digamos, cierta tranquilidad de que en menos de cierto tiempo un atacante podría no obtener información para para acceder a una clave en este caso es que longitud mínima. Podemos requerir al usuario para que la probabilidad de que un atacante encuentre la clave en menos de un año.
Leandro Suarez: o sea que sea menor a 0. Coma 5, La probabilidad, no teniendo en cuenta que son reales alfanoméricas de 36 posible caracteres
Leandro Suarez: y la capacidad de prueba sigue siendo la misma. Entonces, bueno.
Leandro Suarez: acá. Hacemos lo mismo. Pero despejamos la N.
Leandro Suarez: Bueno, acá pasamos todo lo que es el año y terminamos terminar aplicando un logaritmo base 36
Leandro Suarez: para obtener que el largo es tiene que ser mayor igual a 9. Y bueno, ahí 1 puede empezar a jugar
Leandro Suarez: y decir, bueno, exijo 9, 10 o más
Leandro Suarez: con la tranquilidad de que, por ejemplo, exigiendo 9 o más. Sabemos que en menos de un año no se va a poder obtener una una claro con esta capacidad. ¿no? Después, Bueno, puede variar la capacidad del atacante.
Leandro Suarez: La verdad, que siempre es por por segundo, es es bastante igual.
Leandro Suarez: y esto hace que 1 pueda poner a una especie de política de rotación de contraseñas.
Leandro Suarez: ¿qué es lo que se han topado por ahí? Muchos seguro justo. Tengo que cambiar la contraseña. Tengo que hacer algo en el banco, tú crees, pero ahora parió. Bueno.
Leandro Suarez: ¿qué termina pasando el usuario apurado porque tiene que hacer algo. Termina
Leandro Suarez: Oye una contraseña muy sencilla o sin pensarla demasiado, y termina perjudicando al sistema más que ayudando a la seguridad. Entonces esto es peligroso. El tema de la política de rotación de contraseñas sí es muy frecuente y, sobre todo, si no se le avisa al usuario
Leandro Suarez: con anticipación.
Leandro Suarez: Porque, bueno, el usuario psicológicamente va a tratar de de
Leandro Suarez: de complicarse lo menos posible y termina perjudicando a la seguridad del sistema y en sí de su propio usuario.
Leandro Suarez: esto ya lo fuimos y me quedó había quedado. Acá.
Leandro Suarez: Bueno.
Leandro Suarez: ¿qué podemos hacer como sistema para para seguir protegiendo al usuario o para sabemos todo esto que pasa. Bueno, ¿qué forma nosotros igual nos podemos proteger. Es bueno, proactivamente. Nosotros podemos
Leandro Suarez: permite detectar y rechazar claves fácil a la 1. Seis Generalmente, esos los sistemas suelen ya tener algún tipo, Un sistema robusto suele tener algún tipo de detección de clave fáciles o o sencillas.
Leandro Suarez: y rechazarla. Las claves que figuran en el diccionario. Las claves que figuraron en algún league o bridge de contraseñas o información
Leandro Suarez: si contienen algún patrón, se utiliza información de usuario de contexto
Leandro Suarez: de acá. Creo que la uña que todavía no todos implementaron es el tema de las búsquedas en en los Bridges o Leaks, de de la que hubo porque, bueno, eso es un es un poco más complejo, pero generalmente
Leandro Suarez: suelen haber algún tipo de de prevenciones en los sistemas o se espera que los sistemas cuenten con algún tipo de protección proactiva para este tipo de
Leandro Suarez: de
Leandro Suarez: casos, ¿no? Generalmente la clásica que 1 pone su fecha de nacimiento, y no sé, y su nombre y te dice, no no puedes usar datos
Leandro Suarez: propios o personales? Bueno, ese tema no
Leandro Suarez: lo que hablábamos recién el tema de la expiración de claves. Otra forma de proteger, Ok? Bueno, te robaron la clave, o hay una probabilidad muy alta de Te roben la clave cada tanto. Yo te pido que la cambies, cosa que si te la roban, no tengan ser un tiempo menor el que tienen para poder
Leandro Suarez: ejecutar algún tipo de ataque
Leandro Suarez: de esta forma. Bueno, como vimos con la fórmula y demás, podemos determinarlo. Y, como les decía, siempre, mejor dar pre aviso. No es es común que los sistemas corporativos te pidan abajo la política de contraseñas
Leandro Suarez: y que que tenga la empresa, te te pida rotar tu password cada cierto tiempo, ¿no?
Leandro Suarez: Y Y bueno, es que en general se suele pedir que se envíen preavisos. Bueno, que en 7 días se te va a vencer tu contraseña en 5 días. Vence tu contraseña mañana. Vence tu contraseña igual si no la cambiaste
Leandro Suarez: nada, te jodés, Pero en general, bueno, si vos te llega a eso, es Uy en 7 días, una contraseña bueno, listo, mejor. Elijo. Ahora, si estoy tranquilo. Y ese día, si me toca entrar, no tengo este problema, no que que ya venció mi contraseña y capaz, que tengo un problema para entrar. Y si hay algún evento que tengo que
Leandro Suarez: que del cual ser Park, y no puedo tengo que andar buscando contraseña.
Leandro Suarez: Entonces, bueno, hay la mejor forma para evitar que el usuario haga esto de elegir una cocina fácil, poner la misma contraseña también un un número nada más
Leandro Suarez: y bueno lo que lo que a 1 por ahí ha hecho. Yo también me considero culpable.
Leandro Suarez: y esta este sitio. No, lo no lo conozco.
Leandro Suarez: No le puedo hacer clic, pero porque
Leandro Suarez: Nilfam estás seguro que Te Linkedis no es nada raro.
Leandro Suarez: Bueno, algunos sacrificios por mí, y después me hizo
Leandro Suarez: bueno, y después ya entramos en lo que es
Leandro Suarez: un alguna práctica hiper recomendada, por no decir, obligatoria. Hoy en día, en los sistemas de se se auténtica y usuarios.
Leandro Suarez: que es el salking. Básicamente, es salar la información o añadir alguna especie de perturbación a la información que se guarda de forma complementaria.
Leandro Suarez: Lo que se hace es medio símil a lo que vimos para el caso de unix, no que le añadíamos un algo extra a lo que guardábamos. Lo que terminábamos después, fallando o aplicando alguna alguna función
Leandro Suarez: de derivación.
Leandro Suarez: y eso hace que si un atacante consigue una base de contraseñas falladas, por ejemplo, o información complementaria. Bueno.
Leandro Suarez: no puede aprobar primero, no pueda detectar patrones, o sea que tal usuario tiene la misma señal que este otro. Entonces ya con eso tiene información, puede hacer algún tipo de ataque
Leandro Suarez: y tiene que obtener el sal para cada 1, para para cada contraseña de cada usuario, y encontrar eso también, no solamente probar contraseñas y aplicar la función y comparar, aplicar la función y comparar, como habíamos visto, los ataques offline.
Leandro Suarez: Esto le añade una complejidad extra.
Leandro Suarez: Ahora, el algoritmo que se utilice por lo general elige el salta aleatoriamente y lo embebe en el hash.
Leandro Suarez: ¿pero ¿qué pasa?
Leandro Suarez: Uno dice? Bueno, nada Me añadí un poco de complejidad. Nada más tengo que encontrar el sal de alguna forma y seguir probando.
Leandro Suarez: Bueno, estos algoritmos generalmente están diseñados para que ejecutar
Leandro Suarez: el algoritmo, sea costoso, o sea, que no sea tan fácil como listo en 10 ms corre no
Leandro Suarez: tal. Suelen tardar 100 ms para arriba. Y eso hace que, como vimos
Leandro Suarez: el tiempo, digamos que es que requiere el atacante para probar múltiples Powers sea bastante alto y
Leandro Suarez: bueno. Algo importante. Es esto que le decía, así que
Leandro Suarez: no haya 2 2 contenciones iguales. No den el mismo hash o la misma información complementaria, y eso también le suma complejidad a un ataque
Leandro Suarez: de un atacante que tiene una base de datos no.
JOAQUÍN NICOLÁS YULÁN LUCIOLI: Disculpa. Profe. No me queda del todo claro lo que está pasando. Acá Acabo de decir que un atacante tiene tales contraseñas.
Leandro Suarez: El atacante, el atacante. Lo que suele pasar es yo, como atacante logro, robarme una base de datos con contraseña.
Leandro Suarez: La base de datos no tiene las contraseñas. Tiene información complementaria. C, Uno de 2 Cn.
JOAQUÍN NICOLÁS YULÁN LUCIOLI: No tiene contraseña. ¿tiene lo demás.
JOAQUÍN NICOLÁS YULÁN LUCIOLI: Ahora, sí.
Leandro Suarez: Tiene. Tiene la información complementaria en un hash, por ejemplo, que no, no tiene forma de devolverlo al caso.
Leandro Suarez: o sea.
JOAQUÍN NICOLÁS YULÁN LUCIOLI: Claro.
Leandro Suarez: Tiene que probar el agarrar un diccionario, por ejemplo, y empezar a probar pa pa.
JOAQUÍN NICOLÁS YULÁN LUCIOLI: Que tiene que a ese caso.
Leandro Suarez: Que hace. Hash: así. Este hash está dentro de la base listo. Eso ya sé que esta contraseña para este usuario es esta.
Leandro Suarez: Tengo que aparte meterla el hash, o sea, el sal perdón.
Leandro Suarez: Tengo que.
JOAQUÍN NICOLÁS YULÁN LUCIOLI: Tienes que tiene que adivinar también el numerito o lo que sea. El salto.
Leandro Suarez: Sí. Y encima, o sea, no sólo eso, o sea, ya digamos, no puedo paralelizar el ataque porque tengo que encontrar también en sal y aparte, la evaluación de la F es mucho más costosa que lo que era antes, que lo que es para un etiquetado más, por ejemplo, hojas.
Leandro Suarez: Entonces nada se va complejizando cada vez más bueno, y hay algoritmos que que combinan ciertas cosas como el que vamos a ver ahora, que es 1 de los más utilizados que es peor. P, B, K, K, D, F: Siempre me confundo cuando lo digo Ahora que lo leo es fácil, pero hay
Leandro Suarez: la versión, 2 que es hoy es bastante utilizada
Leandro Suarez: junto con otras no, por ejemplo, de creed. También dentro de los sistemas, está bastante probada y bastante robusta.
Leandro Suarez: Por ejemplo, en en en mi equipo lo utilizamos para para fallar contraseñas también.
Leandro Suarez: Realidad no es un hash. En realidad es una la sigla. Es password base
Leandro Suarez: y derivation fanction. O sea, es una función de derivación en realidad, Y lo que hace es
Leandro Suarez: que agarra una password calculo. Un sal de forma aleatoria
Leandro Suarez: utilizan una función pseudo aleatoria que puede ser un criptosistema asimétrico o un mac.
Leandro Suarez: Bueno, lo pasa pasa el el
Leandro Suarez: pasa la contraseña con el salto obtiene un resultado. Por ejemplo, 1
Leandro Suarez: y después iterativamente empieza a hacer como rondas
Leandro Suarez: de lo anterior, de lo que se obtuvo anteriormente y
Leandro Suarez: lo va etiquetando, digamos, con la contraseña.
Leandro Suarez: Y eso al final obtiene j resultados. Y hace un exhort con todo que
Leandro Suarez: a grandes rasgos lo lo que pasa, pues creo que acá más adelante
Leandro Suarez: hay un poco de más de precisión. No vamos a ahondar en esto. Pero como para que vean
Leandro Suarez: que ya es un algoritmo un poco más avanzado, No, esto le da un poco más de complejidad a la hora de evaluarlo, ya no es tan directo. Vamos a hacer un hash.
Leandro Suarez: y
Leandro Suarez: y la cantidad de rondas. La J también suele ser un parámetro. Entonces, ¿vos le puedes determinar n rondas si quieres que sea todavía más complejo, le pone 10 000 rondas, y esto
Leandro Suarez: por 10 000 veces, obviamente va a tardar mucho más. Pero como vos la única vez que lo quieres usar es para callarlo por única vez después o para comprobar cuando alguien se lo vea, no te importa tanto cuanto tarde. En cambio, en atacante si le complica las cosas
Leandro Suarez: porque es siempre exhort. Es porque la tabla de verdad tien y tiene igual cantidad de resultados 0. En realidad mira, la respuesta no la tengo siendo sincero. Creo que va más por un lado, de
Leandro Suarez: uniformizar, digamos, los bits y que no haya ninguna especie de patrón o algo por el estilo que que se pueda llegar a detectar. Imagínense que hay gente que se dedica a estudiar y atacar estos sistemas. Entonces.
Leandro Suarez: de esta forma, generalmente, cuando se quiere, es una especie de uniformidad en los en los datos, se suelen aplicar exhort.
Leandro Suarez: por ejemplo, a E. S. Lo utiliza mucho. No sé si estuvieron estudiando el el algoritmo, pero suele utilizar exor y ese tipo de de operaciones para
Leandro Suarez: para poder, digamos, como hacer uniforme alguna especie de
Leandro Suarez: de de con de secuencia de bits.
Leandro Suarez: Pero el detalle puntual, habría que ir a ver el el el algoritmo.
Leandro Suarez: realmente quizás Pablo tenga la info. Yo ahí me excede un poco.
Leandro Suarez: Bueno, esto Lo bueno de estos algoritmos es que ya están implementados. Por ejemplo, en lenguaje como Java y demás. Por ejemplo, la la librería estándar de Java de Security ya la tiene por defecto. Agarran la la la distancia
Leandro Suarez: con G Spain, el Factory y la pueden utilizar directamente.
Leandro Suarez: no tienen que implementar absolutamente nada.
Leandro Suarez: Bueno, hay otro tipo de de de mecanismos para
Leandro Suarez: para poder para evitar, a veces se para evitar el util la utilización de claves, no para no. Porque, ¿qué pasa
Leandro Suarez: de nuevo? Este tipo de de sistemas requiere que se auténtico un usuario remoto y que ese usuario envíe la clave y a veces, por más que estés en un canal seguro.
Leandro Suarez: envía la clave. Sabemos que es crítico. Igual.
Leandro Suarez: Nada esto de que en alguna comunicación vieja podemos llegar a a descubrir la clave o lo que fuera.
Leandro Suarez: o de alguna forma clickear al usuario y poder obtener la clave.
Leandro Suarez: No vamos a andar en en como, pero una de las formas que que tenemos de evitar que se transmita la clave. Lo menos posible es mecanismos de tipo channel beponse.
Leandro Suarez: Y esto de esta forma evitamos que el usuario envíe información de autenticación y exponerla.
Leandro Suarez: Y es como una especie de validar que el usuario tiene en secreto, lo conoce pero que no lo no lo envía.
Leandro Suarez: Ejemplo de esto.
Leandro Suarez: No voy a ahondar, pero la
Leandro Suarez: no sé si conoce las paskys que están empezando ahora a a tomar mucha relevancia. Si ya a 1 le pasó que que abrió algún sistema o entró a una página o algo y y se quiere generar una paz aquí.
Leandro Suarez: ¿sí? Bueno, y ahí ya automáticamente te dice, bueno, pones un pino, o pones tu cara o pones tu huella? Bueno.
Leandro Suarez: básicamente lo que hace un sistema ya muy groso modo. No hemos. No vamos a entrar en eso en esta materia, pero muy groso modo, el sistema que te crees. Lo voy a dar. Te envío un toque único y vos vas.
Leandro Suarez: Lo está firmando con con de alguna forma la forma en la que lo compruebas a través de un dato que vos conocés, una clave biométrica o algo por el estilo, firmarse ese toque y lo envías. Y de alguna forma, el sistema puede
Leandro Suarez: verificar que bueno firmaste correctamente. Generalmente hay un esquema de clave pública privada de fondo.
Leandro Suarez: Pero hay hay en ese contexto. ¿vos No enviaste ningún dato, ningún dato, secreto, digamos, únicamente firmaste
Leandro Suarez: un Token o un Challenge que te mandó el servidor y se lo devoliste, y el servidor puede verificar que es correcto.
Leandro Suarez: Ese es como
Leandro Suarez: el mecanismo A grosso modo. N: No sé si se le envío un pedido autenticación al servidor servidor te manda un challenge y vos aplicás alguna especie de función
Leandro Suarez: verificando que que que puedes operar sobre ese challenge y después el servidor lo lo comprueba.
Leandro Suarez: Hay un
Leandro Suarez: existe, digamos, el cripten Kiechenge, que básicamente es un poco lo que esto que vimos, Pero aplica una función preacordada sobre sobre la clave, una clave que tiene el usuario y el chain que se le envió.
Leandro Suarez: Y bueno, de esa forma pueden hacer alguna especie de diálogo sobre un canal encriptado?
Leandro Suarez: Bueno, llegamos a lo que a lo que todos estaban esperando, pero lo que ya estaban medio ahí, inquietos de el tema de las claves de Otp o one time password.
Leandro Suarez: y que no hay que confundirlas con Otp, tienen la misma sila. Pero bueno, no tiene nada que ver
Leandro Suarez: y y nada. Básicamente
Leandro Suarez: vamos a andar un poco en los O, T, P, porque porque son lo que más se está utilizando hoy en día con el tema de los celulares y el factor, algo que tengo, y e y es hoy por hoy, el segundo factor que más se está utilizando para los distintos sitios
Leandro Suarez: y las empresas también lo están utilizando bastante, porque bueno, también este tema de la
Leandro Suarez: de que muchos sistemas, o sea, 1 puede tener el audidor a través de muchos sistemas, no Microsoft, Google o alguno que que quiera, digamos que que quiera tener, Digamos
Leandro Suarez: en
Leandro Suarez: así que, bueno, más que nada vamos a a enfocarnos en esto, porque el factor a lo que soy, lo que es más biométrico, ya
Leandro Suarez: excede un poco en la materia pasa a ser más algo de
Leandro Suarez: de reconocimiento de patrones, claro. Tiene otras cosas en juego que que no tienen que ver tanto con la seguridad?
Leandro Suarez: Bueno, y lo que eso te pega a ver.
Leandro Suarez: o Tep, parte de una clave secreta que está almacenada.
Leandro Suarez: Eso tiene que tiene que estar compartido. Eso es así y suelen tener un contador. También.
Leandro Suarez: No hay 2 2 variantes de esto. Tenemos las de H Mac, los o T, P, H, Mak, y los o T, P, Time o de tiempo.
Leandro Suarez: H, T, P, y T, o T, P, los
Leandro Suarez: H. T, pcificados en R. F. C, Si está ahí, 4 26. Lo pueden ir a ver y analizar, pero están tienen como base, una función.
Leandro Suarez: H Bank: Entonces, y
Leandro Suarez: acá lo más importante, que tienen un contador que ese contador está está cambiando. Por lo tanto, está aumentando generalmente y, por lo tanto, cambia después el etiquetado. No, acá lo que se hace es se aplica la etiqueta de chema.
Leandro Suarez: por ejemplo, yo a 1
Leandro Suarez: con la clave y al contador y después se trunca, se extraen 30 de los 160 que te da el mar, y eso es lo que se termina utilizando. ¿no?
Leandro Suarez: Bueno, acá hay más detalles de la implementación, no como como se termina utilizando. Pero básicamente es eso etiqueta el contador y lo trunca para para que no obtener mucho plazo de datos.
Leandro Suarez: el contador va incrementando en cada uso, No, Por lo tanto, requiere que haya una una sincronización entre el servidor y el cliente, y eso se suele controlar con un mecanismo que es el look head.
Leandro Suarez: Y esto hace que el servidor tenga que calcular en intentos hacia adelante.
Leandro Suarez: para que, Bueno, si hay alguna especie de sincronización, lo pueda contemplar también.
Leandro Suarez: A veces, si 1 pide muchos códigos, este no es el más común. Hoy, casi todos son del otro tipo tipo de time. Pero bueno, alguno por ahí queda que 1 va pidiendo, o sea, va
Leandro Suarez: va pidiendo códigos. Entonces puede venir alguien y decirte. Y, claro, el servidor te calcula, no sé, 10 en adelante y vos le prestaste 11. Ya está. Ya quedó de sincronizado. Bueno.
Leandro Suarez: hay formas de volver a sincronizar. Generalmente se tiene que borrar y volver a a asociar. Pero
Leandro Suarez: Bueno, también por ese motivo se aconseja
Leandro Suarez: se aconseja usar alguna especie de trotling del lado del servidor para evitar esto de la de la fuerza bruta. No, como no se actualiza constantemente, 1 lo tiene que actualizar manualmente. El servidor debería tener alguna especie de
Leandro Suarez: de contención contra una especie de fuerza bruta, no empezar a probar código, porque generalmente los códigos son de 1 a 9 dígitos.
Leandro Suarez: se recomienda por lo menos usar S E. I, que es la y suele ser la
Leandro Suarez: el estándar. Y bueno, tenés ahí posibilidades de empezar a a probar, no por más que sea bastante igual. Puedes probar.
Leandro Suarez: Y bueno, quizás lo más
Leandro Suarez: como que los los más utilizados hoy en día, que son los de T o T, P, que está en el R. F, C, Seis, 2, 3, 8 son basados en tiempo. Times tans
Leandro Suarez: utilizan en vez de un contador, utilizan el el Times, tan que está basado
Leandro Suarez: en el car rent, unichtime que vendría a ser el Ebook o basado en la fecha, lo cuenta los segundos desde que se puso en funcionamiento Unic que se considera primero de enero de 1 970 al de 0 0 0 0 0 0.
Leandro Suarez: Entonces lo segundo que pasa en cada momento son esos.
Leandro Suarez: ¿qué es lo que tiene de bueno que cambia sol. Ya es el mismo tiempo el que te va incrementando el contador entre comillas
Leandro Suarez: y por lo general suelen tener este tipo de formatos, O sea, toman el tercero le restan un tercero. En general. El tercero es el tercero, se utiliza el mismo el mismo metal Sam
Leandro Suarez: y lo dividen por la cantidad de segundos de vida que va a tener el código, por lo general también suele ser 30 s. Pero, bueno, varía eso en base a a lo a la crediticia ¿no?
Leandro Suarez: Y bueno. Lo que hacen es más o menos lo mismo, o sea solamente que en vez de usar el contador, lo pedimos, usan el
Leandro Suarez: y ahí eso es lo que utilizan, lo los autenticagators de hoy en día, digamos, y por eso es que cambian constantemente
Leandro Suarez: que qué detalles
Leandro Suarez: a tener en cuenta con esto? Bueno, también tiene que permitirse códigos viejos hasta una ventana de de códigos viejos y una ventanita de código, nuevo porque tema de la sincronización entre los servidores y demás. El usuario vio el código lo puso y ya se venció
Leandro Suarez: bueno, pero todavía te lo toman. Creo que un par de segundos te lo toman. Y y lo mismo, si está de sincronizado y justo, tiene un código antes de que lo calcule. El servidor
Leandro Suarez: también te lo te lo considera. Entonces tiene una especie de drift window. Se le llama
Leandro Suarez: donde aceptan hacia atrás y hacia hacia adelante.
Leandro Suarez: también se aconseja, porque, por más que que vaya cambiando, o sea, la la complejidad es la misma. O sea, si tengo 6 dígitos, estás en la misma. Voy a poder probar por fuerza bruta de la misma manera.
Leandro Suarez: Y
Leandro Suarez: Y bueno, esta clave de acaso lo importante para mencionar es es una clave criptográfica como las que vimos.
Leandro Suarez: estaba generada aleatoriamente y Bueno, cuando
Leandro Suarez: a 1 lo hacen, 1 tiene que escanear el Q. R. No, o a veces se pone un código en el programita en el Google etiqueta o lo que fuera, lo que están poniendo en la representación de la clave
Leandro Suarez: criptografía.
Leandro Suarez: Así que bueno, eso como detalle también
Leandro Suarez: hasta que algunas dudas.
MARTÍN GALLARDO BERTUZZI: Que se le resta había dicho que era fijo o no.
Leandro Suarez: Sí. El tercero sí, por lo general suele ser 0 y sí, debería ser fijo, porque si no te o por lo menos fijo entre distintos.
MARTÍN GALLARDO BERTUZZI: Y que.
Leandro Suarez: No, no, no.
MARTÍN GALLARDO BERTUZZI: Perfecto. Gracias.
Leandro Suarez: Bueno y llegamos a lo que es la parte de multifactor o litigación multifactor que es la el contexto actual en el que estamos o se está empezando a a ver cada vez más seguido
Leandro Suarez: donde, bueno, 1 requiere distintos factores, más de de 1, 2 o más de 2 para poder autenticar una a un sujeto.
Leandro Suarez: lo qué qué es lo que aporta esto? Bueno, que combinar distintos factores y, a su vez, hacer que sea más difícil a un atacante poder comprometer esos factores a la vez. ¿no?
Leandro Suarez: Y bueno, la lo ideal es combinar 2 factores que sean de distinta naturaleza. Por ejemplo, puedo combinar algo que conozco con algo que tengo
Leandro Suarez: donde hay algo que conozco. Puede ser la clave, una contraseña. Y algo que tengo puede ser que como tengo un celular.
Leandro Suarez: me mandan un S. M: S:
Leandro Suarez: Y yo puedo acceder a S. S. M. S, Porque tengo el celular y tengo el chip para donde sea ese S, M. S. O un Whatsapp o el o T, P, No, de que acabamos de ver.
Leandro Suarez: donde yo, a través de mi celular, puedo. Solo tengo que tener el celular para poder acceder a ese código. Entonces, el factor real de eso es
Leandro Suarez: algo que tengo
Leandro Suarez: después tenés, lo que es algo que conozco. De nuevo, la clave más algo que soy, el face id y la huella, la huella, otro tipo de dato biométrico
Leandro Suarez: o algo que tengo. Y algo que soy.
Leandro Suarez: Y ahí entran los celulares.
Leandro Suarez: Los celulares combinan esos 2 factores en un solo dispositivo. Yo lo que tengo en mi celular, y algo que soy es
Leandro Suarez: mi cara, siendo leída por el celular y validada.
Leandro Suarez: Ahora.
Leandro Suarez: ustedes me pueden decir, Che, pero en realidad eso es un medio que es bastante endeble, ¿no? Porque si a mí me me hackean el sello. No sé,
Leandro Suarez: comprometen el celular lo clones, lo que fuera, está comprometiendo los 2 factores a la vez.
Leandro Suarez: Bueno, los celulares No sé si sabían. Tienen un chip dedicado para leer información biométrica al leer y almacenar información biométrica.
Leandro Suarez: Es algo que que va por fuera del del Kerner, del sistema operativo, o sea, que el Kernest no puede acceder a ese chip.
Leandro Suarez: Y en ese sistema operativo lo único que puede acceder es un Ok o un fail a la hora de comprobar la información o
Leandro Suarez: sí, Básicamente, cuando ustedes se ponen la cara. Lo único que hace el
Leandro Suarez: el sistema operativo es preguntar al sistemita que está ahí con la información almacenada, si está Ok, o no.
Leandro Suarez: y después toma una decisión, ¿no?
Leandro Suarez: Entonces, Bueno, tener el el el celular hoy en día
Leandro Suarez: es algo bastante delicado porque, bueno, me lo pueden robar en tu momento. Todos conocemos algún algún que otro caso por ahí de de ataques de agente que le robaron el celular. Y bueno, tienen el chip todo nada. Y pueden hacer algún ataque
Leandro Suarez: medio complejo porque, bueno, asegurar no deja de ser 2 factores de autenticación en un solo dispositivo.
Leandro Suarez: Pero al mismo tiempo es como que, bueno, si vos proteges tu celular y demás tenés 2 factores en un en un mismo lugar, y eso es bastante ventajoso para los sistemas y puede aprovecharse de eso para autenticar a un usuario de forma bastante robusta y segura.
Leandro Suarez: Pero bueno, después, lo que se suele también hacer es lo que se conoce como
Leandro Suarez: este pub autentication donde generalmente 1 le pide al usuario le pide una suela, un solo factor, por ejemplo, la clave, pero quizás con información del contexto
Leandro Suarez: o algún tipo que se detecta algún tipo de anomalía.
Leandro Suarez: dicen, bueno, listo, le pido un factor adicional, porque está en un contexto extraño. Puede ser anómalo. Puede ser que esté siendo vulnerado y levantan un segundo factor. Entonces vos tenés enrolados múltiples factores, pero a
Leandro Suarez: no sé, pero se me ocurre el caso de mercado libre. ¿no? Que generalmente vos te le das con la contraseña, y y creo que tenés distintas
Leandro Suarez: distintas distintos factores: autenticación. Pero el Whatsapp, el face id y algunas cosas más. Bueno, creo que solamente te piden la contraseña, y si que eso es la primera vez que entras en mucho tiempo te piden un segundo factor.
Leandro Suarez: otros sistemas también. Si detectan que te moviste de geolocalización de la que generalmente te conectas.
Leandro Suarez: Te piden algún segundo factor? Y bueno, o te piden que lo enroles en ese momento y después te piden validarlo.
Leandro Suarez: Así que eso también es otro tipo de de implementación que se está usando. Generalmente las empresas grandes lo lo hacen y además, va a variar mucho de del tipo de de información o el tipo de
Leandro Suarez: de de activos que haya atrás de de de esos usuarios. No, no es lo mismo un mercado libre donde tengo las tarjetas guardadas y capaz, te puedo comprar cosas y enviarlas a poner al lado o
Leandro Suarez: no sé, ventas, información de ventas y un montón de información que.
Leandro Suarez: por ejemplo, en un sitio que nada no había un sitio opuesta. Tampoco es todavía más crítico que otro sitio donde yo
Leandro Suarez: cambio cromos de algún jueguito, por ejemplo, que
Leandro Suarez: entonces bueno, nada depende también mucho de la naturaleza de del sistema que y la información que tiene atrás no.
Leandro Suarez: Y este tipo de autenticación también balancea un poco la rigidez entre uy todo el tiempo que me pide el segundo factor de articulación. Te mandamos el celular encima justo. Estoy con la máquina, y no sé, viste. Generalmente el celular. Es algo que tenés encima, pero bueno, igual
Leandro Suarez: es jodido para la usabilidad andar pidiéndole al usuario. Chelo. Fíjate siempre con el segundo factor y demás.
Leandro Suarez: Bueno, y lo que es autización, remota, o sea.
Leandro Suarez: muchas, muchos, muchas empresas dicen que ¿para qué voy a implementar yo la
Leandro Suarez: la autenticación, si ya hay empresas que lo hacen de forma mucho más robusto. Sistemas que ya son super robustos, están especializados en esto, y y yo puedo contratarles esa parte.
Leandro Suarez: ese aspecto para yo enfocarme en lo que tengo que hacer yo un C. R. M, Por ejemplo, se enfoca únicamente en
Leandro Suarez: en desarrollar el componente para para poder y
Leandro Suarez: para para ese tipo de propósitos de aplicación, entonces suelen hacer una especie de legación o tercerización de la aplicación en otro sistema.
Leandro Suarez: Y ahí entran algunos productos de de propietarios, como pueden ser el Iti, director y Federation Service o a D. F. S. Bueno, Casa Sideminder, que, por ejemplo, el acti directory es un producto que es el estándar de de Microsoft para autenticarse.
Leandro Suarez: y muchas empresas lo lo suelen, lo suelen tener contratado para
Leandro Suarez: para identificar y autenticar los usuarios en sus corporaciones. Digamos
Leandro Suarez: si alguno trabaja en alguna empresa quizás lo lo tenga.
Leandro Suarez: Se lo ve mismo: la la el Imba. El Iva utiliza acti directory, sus usuarios, digamos, de ese nombre punto apellido. Nombre apellido arroba algo en el fondo, vive en el acti directory como un recurso que se conecta a otro recurso.
Leandro Suarez: y después surgieron protocolos abiertos, no que nada que que son más para adopción totalmente
Leandro Suarez: de forma libre. Por ejemplo, out. Dos, y después salió arriba de de out. Dos, salió Open E. Connect Open Ey. Uno Openedy 2 quedaron obsoletos. Y ahora lo que se está usando es opening connect.
Leandro Suarez: Muchos confunden o 2 con open ahí. En realidad, lo lo que es Open Id
Leandro Suarez: le añade la capa, la capa de autenticación
Leandro Suarez: a o 2, que es autorización.
Leandro Suarez: No entramos en autorización, pero básicamente autorizar es.
Leandro Suarez: Yo sé que esta este sujeto es este sujeto ya lo auténtico. Pero quiero ver si puede acceder a este recurso correctamente. Bueno.
Leandro Suarez: más más de control de acceso.
Leandro Suarez: Pero, ¿quién identifica quién autentica El usuario es la capa de Open Day.
Leandro Suarez: Esa es una especie de extensión del protocolo de 2, 2, y es básicamente lo que usan hoy
Leandro Suarez: Muchísimas empresas. Cuando te dicen de verdad tengo en Google con Facebook, Apple.
Leandro Suarez: Básicamente terminan delegando la autenticación al protocolo, el protocolo a través de
Leandro Suarez: de los distintos sitios teucática. Entonces el caso de Google quiere hacer algo por mí, o sea, quiere acceder a esta información, Google te asalta la cosa de Google. Y dice: tal sitio, quiere acceder a tu información personal. Bueno.
Leandro Suarez: eso ahí te estaba autenticando y obteniendo información.
Leandro Suarez: Y después probablemente te pida hacer algo. No se quiere acceder a tus archivos y escribir en tu drive Bueno, ahí esos 4 2,
Leandro Suarez: Pero la parte de autenticación de saber quién sos vos. Tu nombre, Probablemente tu foto para después importarlo en el en el sitio en el que estás navegando. Eso era hacer opening
Leandro Suarez: Así que, bueno, eso es un poco.
Leandro Suarez: Los
Leandro Suarez: Las formas de autenticación remota o single si non, como se le suele llamar, No que quiero acceder a tal cosa, listo a Nápolis single si non de la empresa.
Leandro Suarez: Y y de esa forma, no te tienen que crear un usuario. No te tienes que crear un usuario en un sistema externo y demás. El sistema externo integra con con tu sistema de autenticación.
Leandro Suarez: Y como en una especie de federa en login, con lo que
Leandro Suarez: con el que vos ya tenés o con Google directamente, sí lo voy a hacer con Google, con tu propia cuenta
Leandro Suarez: y listo, ese sistema se delega
Leandro Suarez: la autenticación de los de los usuarios.
Leandro Suarez: Bueno, y todo esto que estuvimos viendo, y mucho más, está en el capítulo 2 6 13 de Bishop
Leandro Suarez: del del libro de Bishop, y lo pueden lo pueden ver. Y y bueno, sacarse dudas
Leandro Suarez: y nada y ahondar un poquito más en ciertos temas.
Leandro Suarez: Es que, bueno, no sé si si quedó alguna duda o quieren quieren repasar algo si no
Leandro Suarez: damos por concluido.
Leandro Suarez: Bueno, espero que
Leandro Suarez: espero que les haya hecho llevadero. Es un tema que a mí me gusta mucho porque trabajo. Esto.
Leandro Suarez: Mi equipo tiene una auténtication server y 2 autentications server.
Leandro Suarez: Y es un tema que parece sencillo, pero es más complicado de lo que de lo que suele parecer
Leandro Suarez: y y y es bastante es de las cosas más atacadas. El aspecto más atacados de
Leandro Suarez: de los sistemas, no. Una vez que tersonaste como una como otro usuario. Ya está después el sistema, si no tiene métodos fuertes de detectar qué ese no Sos: vos En realidad, por lo general no lo tiene. Y Y bueno, puedes hacerlo lo lo que vos quieras dentro del sistema, ¿no?
Leandro Suarez: Así que es un punto muy, muy ligado en la seguridad de las aplicaciones.
Leandro Suarez: Bueno, chicos. Listo, entonces estamos por concluido. Espero que, como le dije, que les haya sido
Leandro Suarez: llevadero y que le que le guste.